okay so the boys episode six is now here
and the hero gasmic entry is airtight
with easter eggs hidden details and also
several callbacks to the comics
throughout this video we'll be going in
deep like termite as we run a train on
everything that happens in it so sit
back shut up and pull out your soulja
boy because this is about to get
diabolical now the opening of the
episode somewhat mirrors the ending and
this idea of moments repeating has been
seen throughout the series we had this
scene in which starlight clenched her
fist behind her back which was then
followed up at the end of episode 3.
mother's milk also watched soulja boy in
the tv before he then watched him being
tortured in russia and so on and so
forth in the opening and close of this
episode we get videos filmed on cell
phones and these both have their own
separate meanings the first is an
absolutely hilarious parody of the
imagine video by gal gadot that was
dropped at the beginning of the pandemic
this was pretty tone deaf and it
featured a number of celebrities singing
the john lennon classic gal was trying
to talk about the world at the time and
how we were all in it together which is
something the deep also says
doesn't matter who you are where you're
from
we're all in this together
doesn't matter who you are where you're
from
we're all in this together now we got
criticized because people were obviously
losing their lives and livelihoods andy
pierre is talking about how everyone is
fighting the threat of supervillains
even though the soups are the only ones
that actually stand a chance the video
at the end is stoller exposing the truth
about boredom homelander to her
followers and she's actually putting
herself in harm's way whereas for the
celebrities it's just a hollow gesture
it's clearly just a way for the deep to
have self-promotion and his book deeper
even pops up as one of the youtube cards
in the top corner starlight doing this
of course also mirrors victoria newman
sort of exposing vort earlier in the
season it's an absolutely brilliant way
to open up the episode and i know the
creative team got a lot of flack when
they were writing the season because
they said they'd have elements in it
inspired by certain aspects of the
pandemic there's a number in this
episode but i think they handle them
really well and always take this out of
both sides on it now the video is filled
with celebrities including patton oswald
josh gad mila kunis and ashton kutcher
aisha tyler elizabeth banks kamal and
jani and rose byrne several of these
have already lent their voices to the
franchise including patton oswald kamal
and jani and aisha tyler the latter two
who appeared in the boys diabolical we
then could to crime analytics and see
that the deep has fired everyone there
one thing i didn't notice last week but
did now that they're standing side by
side is that ashley's new ceo suit is
based on homeland escape she's already
copied some of his sayings and this
shows that she's very much mimicking him
possibly because she's afraid now we
then see footage of soulja boy entering
chimp country the carol baskins ask
animal sanctuary that crimson countess
was trying to build the footage here
reminded me a lot of the winter soldier
one from civil war and deep also says
that his face might be cgi in civil war
bucky was framed for an attack on the
united nations and it was later revealed
that he was wearing a
computer-controlled mask that altered
the look of his face homelander is
worried that the entire thing is going
to blow up literally and he mentions
soulja boy's statue being outside of
votawa this was something that we saw in
season 2 and we also opened the season
with a destroyed in episode 1
potentially foreshadowing what could be
coming down the line now ashley says
that soldier boy and crimson countess
were like kurt and goldie and not to
russell and horn who've been together
now for 39 years anyway bit of an early
one but it's theory time every time
they're done
a soulja boy very much represents
someone who can oust homelander and it
is possible that he's cloned from him in
the comics we discovered that homelander
was built using genetic material from
stormfront but for the show the
character was gender swapped to become
homelanders love interest therefore it
could be possible that they ended up
giving this role over to soldier boy
because homelander does need to be a
clone of someone saying as he doesn't
have a father you also find that black
noise sold them out in nicaragua
[Music]
did i actually get that right that time
i think i did it so we find out that
black dwarf was the teammate who sold
him out of the russians look at me
boasting about being able to pronounce a
word that five-year-olds can anyway in
the comics he had a completely different
storyline but learning this later on the
episode makes a lot of sense with what
we know black noir was set on becoming
the face of the group and he hated
having to wear a helmet he clearly
wanted the fame that soldier boy had and
he might have seen getting rid of him as
a way to get to the forefront of the
group anyway that's the end of their
time airtime this still thing i
pronounced it wrong but it's their time
their time a homeland of questions sold
your boy with noir and he sees him as
his loyalist ally in the boy's
diabolical they ended up having a fight
after homelander was worried that he'd
expose him for murdering loads of power
plant workers but noir ended up covering
for him and they've been best mates ever
since however noir ends up leaving
homelander and he cuts out his tracking
device embedded in his arm this explains
how soldier boy was able to track
crimson countess and if you cast your
mind back to the first season then you
might remember that homelander tried to
listen out for the sound of one in order
to find translucent we then go to a
motel where butcher huey and soldier boy
are lying low we see the fast food they
have is vodaburger which we last saw in
laser baby's day out when it come from
there was next to a scientist's alarm
clock soldier boy wants some let's say
racially insensitive source and he can't
understand why they no longer do it huey
ends up having blood coming out of his
ear and it is possible that the effects
of compound v24 could be slowly damaging
both him and butcher this is a black
market drug that hasn't been fully
approved yet and i'd love it if it was
revealed that every time they used it it
killed them ever so slightly now this
would mean they'd have to weigh up
having to fight the supes at the cost of
their own lives and i think it would be
a great reveal later down the line
soldier boy brings up d-day and how
everyone was high on amphetamines which
is actually regarded as a fact according
to several studies the drug was given to
soldiers so that they could beat the
exhaustion that one would feel from
hours of fighting butcher brags about
killing gunpowder to which soulja boy
says it's like killing emmanuel lewis
this actor was best known for playing
webster and his short stature in which
he only grew six inches since his time
on the show more on what other six
inches there are later on and if you're
enjoying the video yet please hit the
thumbs up button and also don't forget
to subscribe for breakdowns on the
series every week now huey tries to lift
soulja boy's shield but he's unable to
the way this is shot is very similar to
the mulia scene in age of ultron and it
cements the idea that he's not really
worthy huey also wears a footloose
t-shirt and this continues his musically
based clothes soldier boy doesn't know
about all the changes in technology
which is of course similar to captain
america who even kept a book on things
that he had to catch up on in the winter
soldier kurta kimako now on her feet in
the hospital she's eating a brave made
rainbow pop which is of course playing
on not only the pride flag but also the
delicious fruit pastel lollies which
sponsor the channel will you guys please
she's trying to reach out to frenchie
and she suggests watching the musical
singing in the rain following on from
last week's 1943 girl crazy which made
her spin off into a fantasy she's
attacked by little nina's forces and in
the comics something similar happened
with payback when she was rested up and
recovering next we join mothers milk and
starlight who are preparing to go to war
on mm's wall we can see a poster for the
black panther movement with the words
move on over or we'll move on over you
this image actually wasn't used
originally by the black panthers and in
fact it was put in place to change
racist laws in alabama even though 80 of
the population was black there they
weren't allowed to vote and this was
used as a movement that organized voter
registration in black neighborhoods the
image of a black panther ended up being
adopted because it's an animal that
defends itself when it feels threatened
very much mirroring mother's milk's mind
state he gives his speech similar to
stan edgar in season 2 and talks about
how he's expected to turn the other
cheek whilst butchering huey can do what
they want he's loading his guns for them
potentially following the ark in the
comics that we talked about in last
week's video it's big spoilers heavy
spoilers you could say so we'll not ruin
it here and not ruin that darth vader is
luke skywalker's father i gotcha you son
of a [ __ ] see you chump
anyway occur to a promotional video for
a train to africa which we discover is
now being made rather than getty images
we have board images over the top of it
and later see that this has temporary
vfx in it a train is badly blue screened
into it as well showcasing he's not
really part of it nor has he ever really
been there it's also on vote soul
showing how they're not really aiming it
for the mass market and are just
pandering to boost a train's image
amongst black people last week he only
brought in blue hawk because he wanted
to boost his image but this backfired
when he paralyzed his brother now he
wants some actual justice and asking for
this makes ashley pull out her hair this
is similar to her comic book counterpart
jessica bradley who ended up pulling her
hair out at the end of the run when she
was set up as a patsy by vote she goes
through all the times vordev had to
cover for his murders and also brings a
pop claw who he killed in the first
season he actually seems like he might
have changed and later on he ends up
apologizing to huey for killing his
girlfriend as she tells him to go
himself finally standing up to his soup
showing how she's now no longer afraid
of them like how she was with homelander
last week deep goes to homelander in the
corridor and behind him we can catch a
poster of the seven in front of the
brooklyn bridge this is riffing on
artwork from the comics and in those
they actually ended up crashing a plane
into it when trying to carry out a
rescue mission on 911. cassandra has
figured out soulja boy is heading after
the tnt twins who are based on the
wonder twins from dc comics similar to
them their powers activate by touching
hands but we learn that they now just
throw orgies that are organized for the
soups eh now in homeland's room he has a
talk in the mirror that reminded me a
lot of the golem scene in lord of the
rings this was recently ripped on a moon
night and we discovered that homelander
has multiple personalities namely one
that always pulls him out of trouble a
homelander is a complete sociopath in
both the show in comics and in the
latter a character disguised as him
ended up carrying out lots of heinous
acts making him believe that he was in
fact insane here however we see that
there exists this darker side to him
that very much enables his behavior
could have the soulja boy movie which is
a parody on both rambo 2 or like first
blood part 2 i think it's called and
rambo 3 which should surely be called
first blood part 3 or rambo 2 at least
never mind now the setup to the scene
here is centerizing the interrogation
one from the second film but the russian
and afghanistan plot was something that
featured in the third film soldier boy
gets angrier which slowly makes his
radiation levels rise showing that the
power is linked to his temper a watching
advert for starlight diapers and soulja
boy asks if men really walk around like
that which ain't no comment now he also
brings a bill cosby in how he used to
make very strong drinks cosby was of
course arrested and jailed a couple of
years back for spiking women which
yeah now after billy gets an address for
hirogasm they load up on compound v24 at
this point we get to the titular event
which probably probably not going to be
able to show any of this but i can talk
about what happened there in the comics
this was a six part storyline that
started in the third omnibus and it
opened with homelander holding a press
conference which is where he gave some
dire news turns out that the battle
light of maritharai war station had been
spotted by saturn and that it was on the
brink of forming a new crisis all the
villains and heroes had put their
differences to the side and they were
going to head out to try and destroy it
what really was going on though was that
they were heading to mcfarland island
off costa rica for non-stop sex
no prices for guessing who the island is
named after and there was a ton of sex
and none stopped messed aborgies on
pretty much every single page however
here's a lovely picture of starlight who
refused to take part much like how she
does in the show now the boys ended up
heading out there to spy on the vice
president and secret service in the
comics the victorian human counterpart
is called vic the veep who's basically
the vp that works for vort stillwell had
summoned him in to tell him that they
were going to launch a coup within the
next year in which vic would end up
becoming the president so that boar
could control everything the boys ended
up kidnapping a secret service agent and
we also learned that at least half of
the organization had now been replaced
by red river candidates you'll probably
remember them as being the organization
that showed up earlier in the season and
as we learned victoria was brought from
here so that she could infiltrate the
government black noir also ended up
sticking his thumb up hughes but at one
point which is when he called him good
soldier and noted the same line from the
dark knight returns now as for the soups
homelander actually had sex with soulja
boy at the event as the latter was
desperate to join the seven and he
pretty much coerced him into it he
rejected soldier boy and said he should
try again next year which is when
homelander realized that he could do
whatever he wanted to homelander then
flew to the sky and destroyed a
passenger plane and at the award
ceremony he planned to announce the
takeover homelander wanted nothing more
than for the soups to unite and rule the
world and he put everything in place so
that he could announce it at this event
homeland even paid off a prostitute to
go and keep stillwell company but he
realized that he was being distracted
and went to the show just as homelander
was about to announce it still well
entered and homeland ended up leaving
the event completely broken the secret
service agent also ended up helping the
boys and he died sacrificing himself so
he could try and save the country from
board's infiltration here it's a lot
more simplistic with the event basically
being a playboy mansion type of thing
that the soups hang out at hang out with
their wang sorry i couldn't resist
moving on
now over on vnn today at today's show
parody homelander says it's safe to go
out and that there is no problem again
this feels like it's heavily riffing on
pandemic responses after the show
victoria and starlight end up having a
confrontation in which she admits that
she's the head popper victoria very much
offers to protect her and says that she
wants to work together but in exchange
for this she also wants her image
boosted starlight ends up turning down
her offer and victoria demonstrates her
power by making her nose bleed
throughout the season we've kinda had
hints to how her powers work with her
exploding jaws and body parts instead of
just heads i actually think that this
shows that she can control blood similar
to the way that magneto controls metal
however it has to be in her sight line
so potentially if she was blinded she
could easily be defeated in the comics
starlet actually blinded a train at one
point because she turned her blasts up
to full power which could be something
that annie ends up doing with victoria
elsewhere friendship is brought in by
little nina and she talks about the
abuse suffered at the hands of his
father bit of a changeup from the comics
as in issue 37 he seemed like a nice guy
now kimiko shows she doesn't need powers
to mess people up and she manages to
escape and save both shuri and frenchie
later on she says that she was always
the monster and it wasn't compound v but
frenchie tells her she's not throughout
the season she's wrestled with whether
she's a weapon i think she's probably
had my favorite arc in the entire season
forgot to point out as well that last
week's musical number might have also
been based on the scrubs episode due to
it taking place in a hospital we then
join starlight and mother's milk and she
asks him why he taps his fingers on the
steering wheel about 20 minutes in a
season 2 episode 4 he also did the same
thing when they were on the road and she
picked up up on this turns out this ocd
came from the night that soulja boy
killed some of his family and he views
taking down the villain is finally
getting him out of his head at hirogasm
they come face to face with love sausage
who in the comics is a character that
ends up working with the boys he helped
them out in russia and also appeared at
several points to take on payback in the
series he popped up in the second season
when he choked out mother's milk which
bit awkward now we also see the
starlight vibrator and several supes
with nods to batman johnny storm with
his johnny on fire iceman from the x-men
and termite returns in the comics we had
a scene at herogasm where there was an
ant-man type character who got told that
he smelt like [ __ ] i also think there's
big game from the comics there but i
can't show you so go watch yourself and
hey put that away will it get disgusted
now outside soldier boy in the group
spying it and we learn that he found it
in 52 with liberty who as we discovered
in the second season was actually
stormfront starlight takes a photo of
deep having sex with an octopus to
blackmail him and i'm glad he found
someone to love after he ate the last
one which i'll never forget i'll never
let me forget you now after huey arrives
starlight tries to get him to clear the
house otherwise people will die but he
refuses to this is obviously going to
cause further strain with them and the
pair teleport outside i love how when
starlight goes back in she's wearing
much baggier clothes because huey
doesn't know how to teleport them yet
huey ends up wearing a neil young
t-shirt so at least he also brought some
spares now after getting covered in some
father's milk at the party mother's milk
ends up wearing the tnt's smile tamara
t-shirt this comes from their merch i
think it's the first time he's worn a
non-related hip-hop t-shirt in the show
this show is also likely riffing on the
simpsons family smile time variety hour
which itself was a play on things like
sunny and cher and the pop hacks who
used to host tv shows in the 70s he
comes across soulja boy and tries to
guess him which was how the russians
knocked him out in the video last week
he takes it like a bong hit and it's
only on butch's invention that soldier
boy steps back mother's milk calls him a
hypocrite because butcher gets to take
out homeland air who he of course
believed killed becker in the comics
homelander actually got her pregnant and
the fetus burst out of her which butcher
then killed we get a split second shot
of a steve garvey baseball mitt and bat
for the los angeles dodgers who he
played for from 1969 up to 1987. getting
ptsd flashbacks soulja boy ignites and
he kills the tnt twins and completely
destroys the house outside a train runs
not only blue hawk but also himself into
the ground
now this is one of the most brutal death
scenes i've seen in the show and he
drags him to his death but in doing so
this causes his heart to give out he
collapses on the floor and my guess is
that he'll recover and blame it on
soldier boy however i don't think that
he's going to be around for much longer
and potentially he might actually have
to stand for something and sacrifice
himself in order to stop homelander this
is something that flash characters have
done before and wally west actually
ended up replacing barry allen for 20
years because the ladder ran so fast in
the speed force that he disappeared he
of course took accountability for robin
but he hasn't made up for supersonic yet
whose death he also ended up causing
termite is stamped out by homelander and
he says to billy that they made a deal
to fight to the death this confirms that
their interaction in episode 1 was real
and that it wasn't a fantasy like what
we saw in episode 2. this conversation
was playing on the brooklyn bridge
encounter that the pair had in the
comics and it very much sets up what's
to come down the line homelander says
soldier boy was his idol and he mocks
him for wearing a cape which yeah makes
sense with his views on the world now
the action scene is probably the biggest
fight that we've had in the series so
far and butcher huey and soulja boy all
team up to try and take down homelander
it's big brutal and they have a bema war
with their eye lasers this is a trope
often used in anime in comic book movies
and it was even made fun of in episode
one with the dawn of the seventh film
they attempt to wrestle homeland down
which feels like the scene in infinity
war where the avengers and guardians try
to restrain thanos homelander manages to
escape though and after starlight
exposes him it seems like he's gonna be
fully off the leash earlier in the
season he brought up his plans to
starlight and now that the secret is out
there it's gonna be interesting to see
if he finally goes through with it in
the comics he didn't actually get
exposed rather he ended up taking down
the white house and president of his own
accord but it seems like they're going
in a different direction here now i
actually don't think that he'll go all
out and destroy everything because the
character has a need to be loved rather
i think he'll try and pass her off as
being a liar who's doing it for
attention and that he'll end up
weaponizing his base against her
homeland's biggest issue is his ego and
also like i don't know if they have the
budget to destroy the uso they might go
that route instead in the scene we also
see starlight's phone case which is
based on her costume and the live stream
is filled with the hashtag vault lied
people died this popped up last season
during the rally with stormfront and
homelander and it's of course playing on
the saying where you insert someone or
something's name in front of it it's
been used recently with a lot of
politicians and countries during the
pandemic and it was also heavily played
upon throughout the iraq war with bush
and blair taking focus we end with
starlight saying that she's quit the
seven and what a way to close out i know
i'm sounding like a broken record at
this point but i think the series is
getting better every week and this was
another brilliant entry shocked at how
far they went with hero chasm and also
how much they're ramping things up i'd
of course love to hear your thoughts so
make sure you comment below and let me
know we are running a competition right
now and giving away three copies of
everything everywhere all at once on the
15th of july and all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now so that's
you then messaging me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the umbrella academy
which will be linked on screen right now
the third season has just dropped and we
go over the very confusing ending and
what it could mean for the future huge
thank you for sitting through the video
up until this point i've been poor i'll
see you next time take care peace